in january 2016 two teenagers from
nashville tennessee named logan
stevenson and j.d bryam attended a
drinking party there was a questionable
concoction being handed out called
dewshine attendees at the party noted
that logan and jd both drank the most do
shine out of everyone the two exhibited
signs of drunkenness and intoxication as
goes with excessive drinking
the next day logan stephenson was found
dead in his bedroom jd bryan died just a
few days later the do shine concoction
they drank was a mixture of mountain dew
and methanol also known as racing fuel
how did the two teens die and why but
first a quick shout out to the sponsor
of this video blinkist okay so you
clicked on this video because you were
curious about what happens when you
drink a poisonous substance right don't
worry i was curious too that's why i
made the video but honestly this video
is just the surface of an ocean of
chemistry knowledge if you really want
to learn more about chemistry or similar
fields like forensic chemistry blinkist
is a great tool for the job blinkist has
a collection of over 5000 non-fiction
titles and condenses the content into
easy text and audio explainers called
blinks i found a blink that fits both my
chemistry and forensic interest the
poisoners handbook is an 18-minute
discussion on new york city's first
toxicologist in the 1920s and his
investigations into a slew of mysterious
poisonings in the city but blinkist
isn't just about science there's topics
on business cooking history true crime
and more there's over 27 categories to
choose from i guarantee you'll find
something right now blinkist has a
special offer just for my audience click
the link in my description to start your
free 7-day trial with blinkist and get
25 off a premium membership try it today
and learn something new methanol is a
member of the alcohol family it's a
single carbon atom bound with three
hydrogen atoms and a hydroxyl group in
contrast the alcohol molecule in
alcoholic drinks is called ethanol which
is similar in structure methanol tastes
and feels similar to ethanol it has
nearly the same physical properties
characteristic burn similar smell and
even causes intoxication yet the way the
body breaks it down is much different
from ethanol methanol itself is not
dangerous but it's what your body
converts it to that is both alcohol
molecules go through two metabolic
conversions ethanol is converted into
acetaldehyde and then acetic acid
acetaldehyde is harmful to the body but
acetic acid is not so damage is reduced
as it's metabolized in contrast methanol
is converted into formaldehyde which is
literally embalming fluid not the best
thing for your body unless you're
already dead remember when i said
acetaldehyde is converted into something
less toxic well that doesn't happen with
formaldehyde in fact it's made into
something even more toxic formic acid
formic acid is deadly because it
inhibits the cytochrome c oxidase enzyme
or the cox enzyme in mitochondria as you
know the mitochondria is the powerhouse
of the cell
it makes the molecule atp so the cell
can use it for energy and live atp is
specifically made by the cox enzyme and
when formic acid binds to the cox enzyme
it prevents the production of atp the
mitochondria is essentially turned off
the cell gets no atp and dies except for
your red blood cells every cell in your
body has mitochondria so all your cells
are affected by formic acid poisoning
think of the mitochondria in your muscle
cells like your diaphragm and heart and
nerve cells in your brain all being
turned off it's easy to see how formic
acid can be so deadly methanol cannot be
distinguished from ethanol so you
wouldn't know if you were drinking it
this is one reason why drinking bootleg
moonshine is dangerous as methanol is
made along with the ethanol in the
fermentation process it has to be
distilled to remove it from the solution
only problem is if it's not properly
removed or checked for its presence you
would never know the first signs of
poisoning in the teens would have been
muscle tremors due to shutdown of
skeletal muscle formic acid would
decrease the ph of the blood making it
acidic the body would respond to this by
increasing breathing to exhale carbon
dioxide from the blood in an attempt to
make it less acidic all the while this
is happening muscle tissue is slowing
down the most crucial muscles being the
heart and diaphragm the final stage of
methanol poisoning is brain death as the
brain shuts down due to lack of atp
the lethal dose of methanol is about 100
milliliters or one-third of a can of
beer and takes on average about 12 hours
to cause death aside from death there is
another terrible effect that can result
from drinking methanol blindness this
doesn't make sense though methanol is a
poison and poisons kill you so how can
you be blind if you're already dead the
average dose necessary for methanol
induced blindness is about 10 to 15
milliliters pretty small in most cases
of methanol poisoning people die instead
of going blind this is because when
people drink they typically have more
than just 10 to 15 milliliters of
alcohol
one of the largest incidents of
methanol-induced blindness was in the
canary islands in 1963
a local winemaker named regelio aguiar
tried to cut costs by using methanol as
a substitute for ethanol in his wine
after a lengthy investigation it was
determined that 51 deaths and five cases
of blindness were linked to the tainted
wine deaths were estimated to be as high
as 1000 but could not be directly linked
but how does methanol cause blindness
after all well say you drink a small
amount that is not a lethal dose the
methanol is converted into formic acid
as you know and will move around your
body via blood circulation if it reaches
the optic nerve in your eye formic acid
will shut down the mitochondria in the
nerve cells and the optic nerve dies the
job of the optic nerve is to send
electrical impulses to the brain to
signal what you're seeing with a dead
optic nerve there's no signal
transmission and you're now blind nerve
cells cannot regenerate like skin cells
or liver cells luckily if given enough
time there is a cure for methanol
poisoning booze
shot a liquor
yes the cure for methanol poisoning is
ethanol whether it be wine beer or
liquor ethanol counteracts methanol
because it's a competitive binding agent
with the enzyme alcohol dehydrogenase
this means in the presence of methanol
and ethanol alcohol dehydrogenase will
preferentially bind to ethanol due to
its attractive molecular structure
with ethanol taking up all the binding
sites for methanol formaldehyde is not
produced no formaldehyde means no formic
acid and the mitochondria in your cells
carries on as normal the unmetabolized
methanol is then excreted into the urine
and it all works out so there you have
it don't drink bootleg moonshine unless
it's been tested for methanol and racing
fuel well that's for cars and ethanol is
meant for you drink responsibly and
while you're at it subscribe too thanks
for watching